i mean look we love these two as friends
and it is a massive betrayal it's
massive it's massive and also it's an
incredibly intense fight i ended my
friendship with theo because of you
one of the only good things in my life
all because of your self-serving
manipulation you have no idea how
horrible it felt to keep this from you
claudia
i mean the fans are waiting with baited
breath we are so excited right off the
bat what would you tell them they are
gonna get in bridgerton season two well
i mean everything they loved about
season one is still there but we've got
the
like the most amazing introduction of a
new family the charmers who are
incredible they're such a rich
vibrant like interesting family to come
into the show you know we're so used to
our little setup now i think we're quite
familiar with everybody so it's really
nice to have that injection of
freshness with the shamans
and um lady with saddam is still very
much at large she's back
and uh i don't think my quest is over
for eloise um and then all of the
delicious costumes and and the music you
know it's it's back and i'm so excited
for everybody to see it i'm so excited i
think fans fell in love with the show
and then since then we've fallen in love
with you all as a family like of actors
what was it like to be back together
again how much fun did you have this
time around especially once you knew the
show had been this huge hit we were just
very grateful to be back with our
friends and to have work and to have a
job we're very very lucky it just felt
like season one again it just felt like
and when we didn't know what it was
going to be we didn't know we were just
on the job and i think it so very
naturally went back to that we just want
to do a really good job there was a
moment just before i remember just
before i as i started i was like oh no i
think i've forgotten how to do it like i
didn't you know i didn't i was nervous
i'd get it wrong like i can't eloise was
a fluke or something but now when you're
there you want you just want to do a
good job and you want the
viewers to love it as much as they loved
season one if not more perhaps this is
not such a wise decision it seemed wise
enough when you took half my pin money
to escort me here i will return it this
part of town is not safe for a young
lady such as yourself take the other
half keep a watchful eye no turning
right now
so bridgerton season two for eloise we
are very much with eloise on the hunt
for ladies
what can you tease about what is to come
between these two dear friends as eloise
tries to figure things out
well eloise is going to make penelope's
life very difficult that's what happened
she's at these balls with her you know
this is where
penelope picks up the majority of her
information you know and these tea
parties these social gatherings
and then eloise is there just right next
to her blocking all those together
everywhere and eloise it's brilliant
she's like oh amazing i don't need to
you know
be at these on my own anymore we can run
off together you know but penelope's
like yeah that's great
you're ruining my job she's like i kind
of need to stay
i've got things to do obviously she
can't say anything and i yeah i think
you're just going to see penelope really
you're just going to have this battle
with what obviously penelope enjoys that
louise company they're best friends but
it's going to make penelope's life quite
a challenge that's what i think we all
be able to see and the dynamics will
shift we are also going to explore a
romance for eloise what can you tease
about what's to come for that we're i
didn't expect this i didn't expect it
either it's lovely isn't it i think
what's exciting is you know
i think what's lovely about the show is
there's no right or wrong way to
to experience romance and love as a
woman in the show and i think more
what's more interesting is to watch
someone like eloise
have romantic feelings i think that's
exciting to see like how does eloise
respond to this sort of scenario but i
think she's found someone that she can
have like really good back and forth
with they make fun of each other they
both are exploring
different ways of thinking that's a real
attraction and it's so cute when did you
find out this would be part of her
storyline and what was your reaction
well when i've got maybe episodes one
and two and then was thinking
huh
something's going on here i was so
excited and callum who plays theo was
brilliant and i you know he was so easy
to work with
and we had we had a lot of fun on on set
together um and we'd like found the
story as adorable as i hope the people
at home well as well yeah yeah i love it
because i mean obviously we love
bridgeton for the steaminess that season
one brought us but this was really a
meeting of the minds with these two and
it was very sweet to see it sort of
innocently um and playfully unfold
yeah it's funny so in the stage
directions
in bridgeton it's really
expressive like they're really fun to
read they're like things are getting
steamy af you know like really like it's
stuff like that
and then with them eloise and theo there
was just one in capital letters that
said nerd swoon
and i loved it so much it felt so
accurate there's eloise and theo they're
young and it's cute and it is like a
little nerd swoon they like reading
together and stuff it's really is
adorable nerd swoon so in the bridgerton
notes it actually says af okay i love
this what's what's like the dirtiest
note you've ever seen in a script betsy
beers who i love is with shondeland
incredible woman she reads the stage
directions in the read throughs and they
couldn't be a better human being to do
it she's incredible at it she really
gets the pace going and so you'll just
hear her being like things are getting
steamy as
like you know like in the
stage it's so much fun she's brilliant
she really keeps the energy up i love
her
i'm so sorry you were right about all of
it i was trying to protect is that what
you were doing
by writing about me in your latest sheet
by telling the entire world about things
i trusted you it was the only way i
convinced the queen it wasn't you was
the only way i could save you the only
person you were interested in saving was
yourself
in the ending eloise has learned the
identity of lady whistle down is her
best friend penelope
what was your reaction when you first
saw that in the script i think i was
really pleased
i was really really pleased that they
did that i think it's a very clever
thing to do because there's no one
you want to find out more is there like
if the stakes are the highest with
eloise like you want that you want that
as a viewer
because the whole time you must just be
thinking she has no idea i can't believe
this like and so i was really pleased
that they did this in the script and
me and nicola were like whoa
i can't believe we're gonna shoot this
like this is wild it's not just like a
screaming match
it's really intense because there's so
much to unpack there's so much to unpack
it's not just the fact you know her
being lady whistle down alone is enough
for eloise to be like what like what do
you mean
but then the fact that
penelope watched eloise for an entire
season you know she saw all of this she
writes about her family you know me and
nicola would talk about it and nicola be
like i can't believe she's doing this
she's so sweet she'd always be like oh
no i can't believe it penelope has quite
a hard time and obviously it would be
very difficult for her to tell eloise
that it's like by the way mate that's me
i'm gonna be using all of you gossip and
i'm going to implement you know she
wouldn't be able to do that so i get it
i get why it would be hard are you and
nicola quite close
yeah we've got like a really beautiful
working relationship
we very much have the same sort of um
objective on set like we really want to
do a good job and get it done and i
think
that makes it very easy we just slot
into
our characters very quickly when we're
together on set i love i love working
with nicola i really do now bridgerton
picked up for season three what would
you hope season three would focus on for
eloise well i hope that they are able to
um
sort out their friendship
you know as soon as possible because i
think i'll find that me and nicole will
be like when are we going to be able to
be together again um so i think that and
also i'd like her to continue
to explore like what we see in season
two and always really explores different
ways of thinking and different groups of
people different parts of society i'd
love to see that expand for her to get
more political what do you think she
does knowing this secret in season three
i think she'll be a good friend that's
what i think eloise will be i think
she'll be a loyal friend and i don't
think she'd tell anyone i don't know
what's going to happen like i mean they
might she might just go out but i guess
i don't think she will i think she'll be
furious
but then just be really respectful
i set them aside for you
i thought
perhaps you might
share your thoughts on them
could we see what about for eloise and
theo in season three i mean could you
film a steamy scene of your own at some
point well crikey i mean yeah
should warn the family i should give
them a bit of a run-up shouldn't i let
mom
listen it could happen to be fair though
when my mum watched season one i think
in her head she was like okay this might
be claudia one day
we're seeing a theme
yeah i think what's interesting about
their relationship is there is a
they're trying to transcend class as
well which i think is
a really amazing thing to explore i love
that he sort of says
he he he's oh okay cool this is we this
isn't working you remind me of like
other debutants i guess you the idea of
being with me is nice but the reality
isn't i think that's really interesting
to explore i'd love to
see them together again
sister oh i am so pleased you were able
to come as if i would allow dear orgy to
miss out on watching his mother win this
little family tradition we do see phoebe
come back as daphne what was it like to
have her return to the world and we get
to see her in the duke's baby she's a
beautiful actress and i you know i
what an amazing person to kick off this
show it's a hard
ship to steer that's a big
um
very courageous thing and she i think
she did it beautifully and it was lovely
to have her back and it was just normal
like all of us always such a family we
really are a family but i couldn't have
been happier to see her i love her very
much we didn't get the reggae cameo that
was kind of thrown out but it didn't
happen right did i miss it no
you're not going to miss that
i feel like i've missed that babe
[Music]
you